dibuja un triángulo rectángulo con dos
ángulos de 45 grados son congruentes
todos los triángulos que satisfacen las
condiciones dadas bueno pues primero
vamos a dibujar el triángulo el
triángulo tendría que tener un ángulo de
90 grados porque tiene que ser un
triángulo rectángulo y los otros dos
ángulos son de 45 grados entonces
tendría que irme para acá ahí está
entonces ahí tenemos este triángulo
rectángulo con dos ángulos de 45 grados
nos preguntan si son congruentes todos
los triángulos que satisfacen las
condiciones dadas la respuesta es que no
por ejemplo aquí tienen lados 4.5 y 4.5
acá y aquí aproximadamente 6.4 pero otro
triángulo que también satisface es
este por ejemplo este de acá a ver si me
queda ahí está que tiene lados 6.2 6.2 y
8.8 de hecho cualquier copia a escala de
este triángulo satisface satisface que
dos ángulos son de 45 y el tercero es
rectángulo todos ellos van a ser
semejantes pero no no van a ser
congruentes vamos a comprobar la
respuesta muy bien